these tuxedoed Wadler czar emperor
penguins you may not know it but these
semi-aquatic birds are some of the most
dedicated parents in the animal kingdom
I mean would you be willing to do what
they do spend 65 days huddled here in
this penguin pack and temperatures that
can drop to a hundred and twelve degrees
below zero
with winds of 50 miles an hour even
Green Bay Packer football fans don't
have it this bad fortunately these big
birds have evolved dense feathers and a
thick layer of body fat the remarkable
thing is the one who incubate s' the egg
and a brood pouches dad meanwhile mom
goes off to sea looking for food
even after the baby is hatched its dad
who keeps the baby in the brood pouch
good thing too just two minutes in the
elements and the chick would be a goner
once mom comes back she and dad take
turns heading out for more food since
they aren't mammals they can't feed
their babies with milk instead they have
to make long often arduous treks to
fishing homes where they can be faced
with huge hungry up to thirteen hundred
pound leopard seals
once the coast is clear of predators the
Penguins dive deep and look up to find
fish swimming just under the ice they're
impressive predators and equally
impressive at evading predators then
back at the Rookery the parent finds his
own chick by voice recognition parent
calls
and baby answers once they're reunited
baby gets to chow down on regurgitated
fish as the baby grows up mom and dad
eventually hunt for its nourishment
together
so remember that huge seemingly
anonymous group of emperor penguins well
groups like that are made up of
committed parents working in tandem
great parents lucky kid